how's it go brothers bit ah today you
and I are gonna make some babies
Oh God put your clothes back on the [ __ ]
so as he was on Twitter which one of
your ships would you like to see a baby
up let's make some babies of course
Larry comes up they both have pretty
good DNA like it can't it can't be that
bad
this should technically be an attractive
baby Oh God alright let's add Louise in
there hahahaha before after
god damn you're walking for the
nightmares let's see what you must think
Oh nope it's how can i unsee kill it
the next suggestion is me and Edgar okay
hey did you hear there we're gonna have
a baby get up just language slave you
[ __ ] I love how every picture of Edgar
just looks like he saw a giant [ __ ]
let's start off with me because
everything is about me I mean that's one
attractive baby right there
does it look at that beauty now let's
apply it why why do I have to do this
okay I'm actually terrified um I don't
know what happened with my pug
all right well remind me to never ever
ever ever have a baby with my dog oh god
let's just let's just close that one and
pretend it never happen next ship is
Obama and Taylor Swift
okay so we have Obama we have Taylor and
let's make a baby
the foots [ __ ] terrifying all right
there we go that looks green now let's
throw a little Taylor DNA into the mix
and see what happens
cuz the players gonna play play play
play play
I don't know what I'm doing but I know
it's not holy and I know I'm probably
going to hell
what if Barack Obama and Taylor Swift
had a baby I want to adopt that kid yes
we can shake it off next one suggested
is Morgan Freeman and my girlfriend
Marcia let's let's see what'll be
resuming all right there's my tea app
that looks great don't kill me please
mmm let's do a little Morgan Freeman in
there it's why the [ __ ] not
I am already terrified oh god no no no
get off my girlfriend Morgan Freeman and
look it's it's a demon it's a it's a D
it's a demon okay let's just say that
one get it out of the way and then we
can move on with our life why did Morgan
Freeman and maxi-pad I had a baby oh
great
everyone is laughing this is not funny
all right it's not funny
kill it before it lays eggs beautiful
baby no no if I go that far next one it
is snatched gray and Hitler let's find
out what their babies look like baby
baby baby oh Henry looks like a potato
ah that looks cute hi nice okay Wade
emoji sorry hahaha you need help
looks like my toe you have problems so
kawaai that's what I said okay
the most suggested one is definitely Dan
and Phil everyone wants to [ __ ] see
their baby well guess what it's gonna
happen how about they have this cat
thing going on what if they yet give
birth to a kitty wouldn't that be
wouldn't it make sense for them to give
birth to a kitty
alright Dan and Phil let's studious I
feel like Dan's hair should stay
definitely a wise decision okay they
look kind of scarily similar like I
can't even tell a difference
like what happened I'm gonna let this
one just stay in hell where it belongs
hope you brothers had some fun making
babies with me today leave a like if you
did I really appreciate it thank you for
watching as always it's a sky to come
abroad today and as always I said that
twice as double always stay off